To compete with Airbus,...
...Boeing's obvious move was to upgrade the engine on their single-aisle plane, the 737,...
...but there is one issue.
Here's a sketch of the 737 next to the Airbus A320.
Notice how the 737 is lower to the ground than the A320.
This meant Airbus could slide a new engine under the wing of their A320,...
...but there wasn't enough room under the wing of the Boeing 737.
Their solution was to move up the engine on the wing so that it would be slightly higher....
...and it would fit on their 737s.
When the 737 MAX was in full thrust, like during takeoff,...
...the nose tended to point too far upward, which could lead to a stall.
This was a problem because these planes were supposed to behave exactly like the old ones,...
...so Boeing came up with a workaround.
Instead of re-engineering the planes,...
...they installed software that automatically pushed the nose downward...
...if the pilot flew the plane at too high of an angle.